es geht los die vorbereitung zur
besiedlung des mars haben tatsächlich
begonnen jetzt an ihnen max seine pläne
für die mars besiedelung zum ersten mal
detailliert geschildert und er hat den
stand der entwicklung dokumentiert das
verrückte der brause riesigen
raumschiff für den flug zum mars hat
bereits begonnen
jetzt also der stand der vorbereitungen
zur marktentwicklung endlich zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen ihnen masken
wirklich verrückt wenn er etwas
ankündigt dann haben die vorbereitung
meisten zum begonnen oder es geht schon
bald los versuch so maaß ist er mit
seinem raumfahrtunternehmen spacex schon
voll dabei jetzt hat er seine pläne im
fachmagazin new space veröffentlicht
und es ist absolut beeindruckend was er
vorhat und wie weit er schon bei der
konstruktion des mars raumschiffes
hauptherausforderung für den flug zum
mars sind dabei die kosten im moment
würde der flug zum mars zehn milliarden
dollar kosten und da sich die kosten
für einen flug sondern pro person
liegen also fünf astronauten zum mars
sind ist von 50 milliarden und so weiter
waffeln immense kosten die sechs
nationen wie die usa kaum aufbringen
können macht will die kosten so denken
dass privatpersonen sich den flug
dorthin leisten können er stellt sich
vor dass ein flug ungefähr so viel
kostet wie ein kleines einfamilienhaus
rund 200.000 dollar hatte in dem artikel
damit ist der flug 60.000 dollar teurer
geworden weil seiner letzten
präsentation aber er stellt sich vor
dass dann einmal mit regelmäßigen
flüge zum mars bekommen der preis auch
auf 100.000 dollar sinken könnte je
nach menge des gepäcks jedes kilo
verursacht bei einem deutschen flug
immense kosten um die preise zu senken
hat macht ein paar bahnbrechende ideen
so sollen die raumschiffe nach dem start
direkt im auge wieder betankt werden
dadurch sind die raketen für einen
mars-flug deutlich kleiner zu
dimensionieren riesige mengen treibstoff
werden einfach beim zweiten start zum
raumschiff transportiert trotzdem werden
die raketen für einen mars-flug die
größten die je von der erde gestartet
worden
bisher war die saturn 5 rakete die
stärkste gebaute die transportierte die
apollo kapsel mini weltraum bei dem
wurde keine stärkere
gebaut das maß wenige wie das projekt
zur zeit noch heißt soll sie
übertreffen um das vierfache
während die saturn 5 135 tonnen in den
orbit also zum beispiel zweier tests der
internationalen raumstation
transportieren konnte ist dass michael
in der lager 550 tonnen dorthin zu
transportieren und durch die idee das
raumschiff im orbit aufzutanken steht
eine hohe nutzlast dann auch für den
flug zum mars zur verfügung
dort macht denkt dass die kosten allein
um das fünffache
entscheidender punkt ist auch die
wiederverwendbarkeit der elemente der
buchbar
aber die erste stufe soll 1000 mal
wiederverwendet werden können
der tanker immerhin 100 mal und das
raumschiff 612 mit dem bus der fall
reinhardt space extra schon eine menge
erfahrung gemacht und die kosten
deutlich senken können und auch der
austrag verbringen ist der graf zum
ersten mal erfolgreich wiederverwendet
worden und zum zweiten mal zur iss
geflogen maske ist also auf einem guten
weg und noch etwas soll die kosten
deutlich senken
100 bis 200 menschen sollen in den mars
raumschiff platz finden
mit 1000 solche schiffen bilder macht
dann den mars besiedeln jedes schiff
soll dank zehnmal zum mars und wieder
zurückfliegen bedarf nach 50 bis 100
jahren eine stadt mit einer million
einwohnern dort entstehen könnte und
macht schon mit dem bau der rakete
begonnen
eine herausforderung ist sehr der
leichtbau der neuen rakete soll auch
carbon hergestellt werden was
insbesondere bei dem bau der tank nicht
gleich des carbon tanz waren bisher
weniger dicht als aus metall
hergestellte tanks ettlingen hat sich
machen dieser schwierigen aufgabe als
erstes gewidmet der erste riesen st ist
bereits fertig und wird zurzeit getestet
zwischenergebnis er ist nicht ein erster
meilenstein ist also bereits erreicht
und schon bald will mit dem ersten
dragon zwei frachter zum mars schicken
und dann ab 2020 den regelmäßigen
flugbetrieb aufnehmen maske ist klar
dass das sehr ehrgeizigen viele sind
doch eher wenige schwierigkeiten auf dem
weg dorthin
ich würde mal sagen schauen wir mal
wann das realität sobald es etwas neues
dazu gibt der vater ist natürlich hier
wenn er kein video verpassen wollt dann
würden wir hier ein abo aufsaugen
vergessen ich den
auf die glocke der mann bekommt der
mitteilung wie klicks um hat einen mega
struktur aufgeklärt viele freuen uns
über solche nachrichten
hier geht es weiter mit meilenstein der
raumfahrt den video über den ersten
flug einer wiederverwendeten dragon
kapsel und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran